in nine months and you haven't acted a
horse yet sheets with the secretary
every time it goes with a office yeah I
made a mistake you ready mom
and you are no I'm staying next door
away from her how cool you're not from
around here no it was this accident with
my folks I'm gonna finish up in Monroe
High I don't teach this action seems too
cool to be a teacher I'm sorry I
shouldn't it's okay
the nicest thing anybody's said to me in
a long time well then I'm glad I said it
and you used some of your life you start
to feel like I don't belong in here
our judgments
just us look at Noah I was feeling
vulnerable I'm an adult I wasn't
thinking clearly
I can't do this you know it you won't
stay for dinner
hey mrs. Peterson John what happened
this weekend what am
oh there was there was a big
thunderstorm you guys didn't get it up
there
Oh your eyes the bonnet the lake well it
got pretty wet here good news I've
approved your request for Noah Sandborn
is on your class did you send an email
from my account sounds like you've been
hacked
she really changed password your father
seems to be around a lot now huh
yeah I guess don't forget that he walked
out on you how do I need you to stay
away from Noah okay see you at school oh
good job
for me I can't do that Claire I live
next door
do you want to take a cookie for the
road
hope your mother's cookies